Wir haben neue Produkte bei wish, joom und aliExpress
bestellt. Bekommen haben wir unter anderem eine Reihe
minderwertiger Sachen: Einen Saugroboter, der nicht saugt.
Eine Drohne, die nicht fliegt. Ein Parfum mit verbotenen
Substanzen. Und einen E-Scooter mit krassen Sicherheitsmängeln.
Also das ist wirklich gefährlich.
Das ist Online-Shopping auf einem ganz anderen Niveau:
Je billiger, desto besser. Obwohl die Qualität der
Produkte teilweise echt schlecht ist, gehören die
Plattformen zu den beliebtesten Shopping-Apps.
Da stellt man sich schon die Frage:
Wie kann das sein?
Man muss schon zugeben: Es ist einfach oft witzig,
sich hier Produkte anzuschauen und Sachen zu bestellen.
Die Werbung dafür ist absurd, mache Dinge sind so unfassbar
billig und andere einfach nur absolut merkwürdig.
Und sobald ich auf diesen Seiten bin, bekomme ich das Gefühl,
ich sollte jetzt auch etwas bestellen. Obwohl ich gar nichts
brauche, will ich etwas haben.
Wie das sein kann, habe ich einen Experten gefragt:
Da wird generell so aus einer psychologischen Perspektive
eigentlich alles gemacht, was so in so einem Lehrbuch steht,
damit man die Leute auch zum Kaufen verführt.
Professor Kenning ist Experte Neuromarketing.
Das heißt dafür, wie man Erkenntnisse aus der Psychologie
und der Hirnforschung mit Marketing verbindet.
Er kennt also alle Tricks, die dafür sorgen können,
dass wir mehr kaufen als eigentlich geplant.
Wenn man das rein ökonomisch betrachtet, dann haben diese
entsprechenden Produkte und Angebote ein sehr, sehr gutes
Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis. Zumindest auf den ersten Blick.
Vereinfacht gesagt, es ist billig. Und wie billig es ist,
zeigen die Seiten durch Streichpreise und absurde Rabatte
von bis zu 90%.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich kaufe mich reich. Ich könnte im
Prinzip dadurch, dass ich was kaufe immer reicher werden.
Weil, das kostete ja mal 100 € jetzt sind es nur noch 11.
Also das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein.
Das ist ein Faktor, der sich auf unsere Kaufentscheidung
auswirkt. Ob die Rabatte echt sind oder sich auf verbotene
Mondpreise beziehen, ist zudem schwer zu kontrollieren.
Das Zweite ist das Element der kognitiven Dissonanz, wo man
versucht, den Leuten die Angst zu nehmen, einen Fehlkauf zu
tätigen, u.a. mit Referenzen auf andere, die gekauft haben,
durch Bewertungssysteme und so weiter. Das Dritte ist
sozusagen dieses Thema der Fear of missing out:
Wenn ich das jetzt nicht kaufe,
dann verpasse ich was.
Was genau passiert da in unserem Kopf?
Immer dann, wenn ich ein attraktives Produkt sehe, das mein
Gehirn ein Belohnungssignal erzeugt. Da sehe ich einen
schönen Artikel und möchte den haben.
Die 2. Struktur ist dann der Preis. Das heißt, ich sehe
dieses Produkt, möchte es gerne haben, schaue jetzt auf den
Preis und denke aber: Ohhuu, das ist jetzt aber teuer.
Und diese beiden Impulse „Möchte ich gerne haben“ vs.
„Oh, das ist aber teuer“, die werden in den präfrontalen
Cortex, also unser Stirnhirn projiziert und da findet
jetzt die Kontextualisierung statt. Also zum Beispiel werden
da dann bestimmt Informationen kontextualisiert, wie jetzt:
Bald ist wieder der Erste, dann habe ich mehr Geld.
Und diese Impulskontrolle kann man beeinflussen und
unterdrücken. Zum Beispiel über die Streichpreise, über
Produktbewertungen, Pop-up Fenster, Countdowns, Garantien usw.
Hinzu kommt dann noch der Game-Faktor: Bei Wish gibt’s
zum Beispiel ein Glücksrad und man wird dafür belohnt,
wenn man mehr kauft. Oder einfach dafür,
dass man die App jeden Tag öffnet.
Wenn ich jetzt solche Spiele mache, dann aktiviere ich das
Belohnungssystem und wenn ich Preissenkungen mache,
deaktiviere ich dieses Preis-Schmerzsignal und wenn ich
dann noch sage: Jetzt musst du aber schnell kaufen, weil
das Produkt ist nachher weg. Dann setze ich diese
Impulskontrolle unter Druck. Und das führt dann
letztendlich zu diesem manifesten Verhalten, ich finde den
Artikel toll, will den unbedingt haben, ich habe weniger
kognitive Kontrolle, weil ich abgelenkt oder unter Druck
gesetzt wurde und man gibt mir den Hinweis: "Mensch das ist
doch total günstig, kauf das doch."
Und dann noch mit der starken Marke ggf. 'ne Rolex für 26€
die schon 6.000 Leute gekauft haben. Da kann ich ja nichts
falsch machen, da muss ich jetzt aber schnell kaufen.
Mehr Belohnung, weniger Schmerz und weniger Impulskontrolle.
Das ist die Neurophysiologische Erklärung.
Wenn Sie da Autos verkaufen würden oder Häuser über diese
Plattformen, das würde nicht funktionieren.
Deshalb geht es um Schmuck, Gadgets, Kosmetik, Kleidung,
Krims Krams. Dinge, bei denen wir nicht so viel nachdenken.
Mit viel Glück kann man schon ein Schnäppchen machen. Dass
die Wenigsten edle Produkte für ein paar Euro erwarten,
ist auch klar.
ABER: Viele Verbraucher sind auch gefrustet.
Allein bei den Sachen, die wir bestellt und getestet haben,
ist das Ergebnis wirklich bitter. Von 15 Bestellungen sind
nur 11 überhaupt bei uns gelandet.
Viele Produkte waren gefälscht, in der EU gar nicht
zugelassen, minderwertig oder sogar gefährlich.
Es gibt viele Menschen, die dieses Wissen über
Produktqualitäten nicht haben und sie sollten es auch nicht
unbedingt haben müssen. Weil wir eigentlich in Deutschland
es so organisiert haben, dass es Kontrollsysteme gibt, die
dafür sorgen, dass wenn ich Produkte im Handel kaufe,
ich mir keine Sorgen machen muss, dass da giftige oder
schädigenden Inhaltsstoffe drin sind.
Und genau das klappt aber offensichtlich nicht.
Es kommen Produkte an, die nicht sicher sind, denn die
Marktüberwachung ist in Deutschland noch nicht im Neuland
Internet angekommen. Außerdem haben wir in Deutschland ein
recht komplexes System aus unterschiedlichen Ämtern, die
für Marktüberwachung und Produktsicherheit zuständig sind.
Der Markt ist kaum kontrolliert und wir Verbraucher sind
damit nicht wirklich geschützt.
Also, es macht einem schon Sorge, wenn man sieht, was hier
so alles reinkommt. Was die Leute sich alles so bestellen.
So viele Mengen, die da kommen.
Jeden Tag kommen allein am Flughafen in Frankfurt etwa 450.000
Päckchen an. 80% davon aus dem asiatischen Raum. Dort, wo
auch die meisten Händler der Plattformen
produzieren und sitzen.
Nur, damit ihr mal eine grobe Vorstellung davon habt:
Allein die Bundesnetzagentur hat im Jahr 2018 über 10 Millionen
Online Shopping-Produkte aus Verkehr gezogen. Weil die
Produkte gefährlich, weil sie gefälscht oder einfach
nicht gekennzeichnet waren. Trotzdem schaffen es viele
der Produkte ganz ohne Kontrolle zu uns nach Hause.
Das ist vielleicht auch ein Problem der Kunden, aber das
ist in erster Linie sozusagen ein Problem derjenigen,
die die Kontrollfunktion haben.
Fassen wir also zusammen: Die Plattformen sind extrem
billig und nutzen viele Strategien, um uns zum Kaufen
zu animieren. Rechtlich gibt es allerdings einiges an
Grauzonen und es wird wenig reguliert. Aktuell ist der
Staat mit den Kontrollen überfordert und wir Kunden können
uns nicht wirklich darauf verlassen, dass wir ein gutes
oder unbedenkliches Produkt bekommen.
Aber natürlich zwingt uns niemand, diese Plattformen zu
benutzen. Und ob es sinnvoll ist, sich dort etwas zu
bestellen wenn man nicht weiß, was für eine Qualität
man erwarten kann, das muss jeder für sich selbst
entscheiden.
Habt ihr dort schon mal was bei joom, wish oder aliExpress
bestellt? Wenn ja, schreibt mal in die Kommentare was es
war und ob ihr damit zufrieden wart.